- [Gary] How old are you?
- [Guy] I am 27.
- [Gary] You've got fucking time.
It's a balance of regret and patience. - [Guy] Ok
- Like you can go hard on for a 3 years,
do nothing right,
wake up
and be young as fuck.
You should really go to retirement home one day
and volunteer and just talk to them.
It will make wanna do shit
every minute in your life
because when you see regret
in the men's eyes
it's fucking painful
because you can't do shit about it.
When you are 90
and you are not mobile
and if you are tired and it's over
you can't do anything
you can't do it
you can't build that company you wanted
you can't spend that time with your kid
it's regret - [Guy] Yea.
- and it fucking drives the shit out of me
Gary Vaynerchuk